[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur sensation
avec le soutien financier du fond
citoyen franco-allemand bonsoir et
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de zone
Europe sur Radio sensation et sur TV 78
une émission spéciale enregistrée à
Berlin en Allemagne avec le soutien du
fond citoyen franco-allemand nous
parlerons dans cette émission de la
législation sur le cannabis de spectacle
et aussi des traditions de Noël avec nos
sens à Reporters anajoute et Cécilia ROV
elle partageront avec nous leur
découverte et leur rencontre mais tout
de suite il va être question du devoir
de mémoire j'ai rendez-vous avec
Christine gleoning elle est responsable
du centre de documentation sur le
travail forcé
bonjour Christine gloning bonjour merci
d'être avec nous dans une Europe first
can you introduction
cette exposition est dédiée au camp de
listerfield sud situé au sud de la ville
de Berlin
nous racontons l'histoire d'un camp de
prisonniers de guerre française encore
inconnue il y a quelques années environ
2500 hommes étaient internés dans ce
camp de travail et condamné au travail
forcé nous racontons l'histoire de ce
camp mais nous racontons aussi
l'histoire de ce site historique
redécouvert il y a quelques années et
l'histoire de l'engagement de citoyens
et citoyennes qui ont lutté pour que cet
endroit et ses baraques qui existent
encore soit préservés et qu'on en fasse
un lieu d'apprentissage et de
commémoration
nous avons constaté au fil des dernières
années que l'on découvre encore
d'anciens camps de travail à différents
endroits de Berlin
beaucoup à Berlin notamment des
immeubles d'habitation et des écoles et
régulièrement on découvre des sites dont
on ignorait l'existence des endroits où
logés des travailleurs et travailleuses
forcés pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale qui travaillait à différents
endroits dans la ville et nous avons
pris cet exemple de leaderfield Sud pour
raconter l'histoire d'un camp presque
entièrement tombé dans l'oubli et le
fonctionnement du système de gestion des
prisonniers de guerre de Berlin il y
avait le Stalag 3D le grand camp central
et contrairement à d'autres endroits
organisés autour d'un camp central à
Berlin il y avait un réseau de
différents camps et le camp de
listerfeld était l'un des plus grands et
l'un des plus importants
quelle est la réaction des visiteurs
qu'est-ce qu'ils apprennent à travers ce
projet
les personnes qui viennent visiter le
site en apprennent plus sur l'histoire
elle découvre l'histoire de ce camp de
prisonniers de guerre elles en
apprennent plus sur la situation des
prisonniers de guerre français qui pour
certains ont passé 5 ans internet à
Berlin dans ce camp de listerfeld sud
elles en apprennent plus sur le
quotidien le travail forcé le peu de
temps libre qu'ils avaient et la
situation dans le camp dans l'exposition
on découvre les biographies de
prisonniers de guerre français mais
aussi d'Édith Piaf par exemple qui était
considéré comme la marraine du stalag 3D
et s'est rendu à Berlin plusieurs fois
pendant la guerre notamment pour chanter
pour les prisonniers de guerre français
quel message voulez-vous passer à
travers cette exposition
on aimerait que les visiteurs et
visiteuses soient attentifs et attentive
aux endroits historiques à Berlin ou
ailleurs
on peut aussi partir sur les traces de
l'histoire du lieu d'où l'on vient et
essayer d'en apprendre plus sur
l'histoire d'autres camps de prisonniers
de guerre entrer en contact avec des
proches ce qui était précieux pour nous
c'était l'échange avec les proches grâce
aux réseaux sociaux il y a un groupe
Facebook qui s'appelle prisonnier de
guerre et cela nous a permis de
contacter Agnès tanière par exemple la
fille d'un prisonnier de guerre français
interné ici à listerfel Sud il y a
encore de nombreuses traces à découvrir
et on aimerait que l'exposition incite
les personnes à partir à la découverte
d'autres traces historiques ta semaine
merci beaucoup donc
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous dans une Europe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous voici sur la belle place c'est ici
que se déroule jusqu'au 31 décembre le
veinard zobber l'un des plus célèbres
marchés de Noël de Berlin et je suis
entouré pour cette émission de nos sens
à Reporters bonsoir Cécilia Rove et
anachute bonsoir on va s'intéresser
d'abord au cannabis avec Anna
l'Allemagne envisage une légalisation du
cannabis à usage récréatif effectivement
Corentin je me suis rendue au musée du
chambres ont lieu unique à Berlin pour y
rencontrer Stephen gaillard président du
Canal+ social club allemand en militant
de la légalisation du cannabis
que signifie la légalisation du cannabis
la légalisation du cannabis signifie
tout d'abord que dans notre société
beaucoup de gens pourront vivre une vie
plus libre et plus saine nous avons un
grand problème en ce qui concerne la
circulation clandestine de cannabis avec
des addictifs nocifs pour la santé des
diluants des cannabinoïdes synthétiques
et tout cela prendra fin on observe pas
ce phénomène dans la vente d'alcool en
Allemagne et cela permettra à la police
de s'occuper des crimes plus importants
donc des cambriolages des vols de
véhicules des viols toutes ces affaires
qui ne sont pas traitées aujourd'hui car
on chasse les petits fumeurs
quelle conséquences négatif ou positif
cette légalisation
pourrait-elle avoir
la légalisation créera 10 000 nouveaux
emplois je pense que ce sera une
évolution positive pour notre société
cela générera également un revenu fiscal
de 2 à 4 milliards d'euros annuels qui
renflouent actuellement les caisses de
la mafia je vois cela comme une
évolution positive il y aura également
des perdants sur tous les personnes sans
permis de travail qui dépendent du
revenu généré par le trafic de cannabis
trafic d'une substance peu dangereuse
comparé à d'autres substances cela
seront en difficulté lorsqu'il n'y aura
plus de consommateurs qui viendront
acheter ici à la sauvette aux gorzzi
leur parc ils devront se trouver une
autre activité qui les exposera
potentiellement à plus de violence et le
répression mais la société dans son
ensemble bénéficiera de ce changement
nous aurons un accès facilité au
cannabis médical nous verrons une
renaissance du chambre industrielle tous
ses effets sont les retombées positives
de la légalisation que nous ne pouvons
pas encore chiffrer
quelles sont les actions que vous menez
en faveur de cette légalisation quel
obstacle reste-t-il à franchir nous nous
trouvons au musée du chanvre à Berlin
depuis 1994 nous faisons un travail de
sensibilisation et d'éducation classique
nous informons des personnes de 666 ans
tous les jours sur les nombreux usages
de cette plante nous expliquons qu'il ne
s'agit pas juste de quelques fleurs dans
un sachet plastique mais qu'elle a un
grand potentiel pour l'être humain et
bien sûr nous nous occupons aussi de la
politique j'organise notamment la plus
grande manifestation pour la
légalisation du cannabis en Allemagne
une fois par an nous organisons la
parade du chanvre et parlons directement
avec les représentants politiques mais
je suis également engagé à d'autres
niveaux je participe à des débats
publics et essaie de convaincre les
sceptiques ceux qui ont peur de la
légalisation que ce sera un plus pour la
société de se défaire de cette
interdiction erronée
on est ici au musée du cannabis
qu'est-ce que le public vient chercher
[Musique]
nous partons du principe que le public
en sait déjà beaucoup sur le haschich et
la marée Roanne cela ne représente donc
qu'une petite partie de la discussion
par plutôt sur ce qui ne savent pas on
leur montre la plante dans son entièreté
on leur explique les différentes parties
de la plante et son importance pratique
par exemple en tant que matériaux
textile pour la production de papier
pour l'alimentation sous forme de
graines et d'huile on se concentre sur
le potentiel médical du cannabis et
enfin tout à la fin on parle de ce qui
préoccupe le plus les gens le cannabis
et la politique des 50 dernières années
il faut clarifier quelques aspects
surtout au niveau des personnes plus
âgées nous avons constaté qu'il y a
beaucoup de crainte autour du cannabis
qui ne sont pas forcément justifiées
personne n'est mort du cannabis par
exemple il y a beaucoup de propagande à
ce sujet que nous cherchons à contrer au
musée
à présent avec Cécilia on va découvrir
une artiste spécialiste de l'effeuillage
ici en Allemagne on l'a considère comme
une référence dans le milieu du
burlesque il s'agit de Marlène von Steen
vaag elle est elle-même à l'origine d'un
festival Cécilia exactement Corentin en
fait le burlesque c'est un peu la
grand-mère du strip-tease femme comme
homme vienne en fait jouer avec leur
corps avec glamour mais aussi avec
humour pour venir faire passer des
messages et également raconter une
histoire Marlène Weinstein vague en fait
elle est venue raconter à la caméra de
radio sensation les spécificités du
burlesque et du cabaret allemand
bonjour Marlène
qui êtes-vous et que faites-vous
bonjour nous nous connaissons depuis
quelques années maintenant je suis une
danseuse de burlesque depuis plus de 10
ans basé à Berlin
du festival burlesque de Berlin et de
Hambourg et aussi de l'Académie
burlesque de Berlin
j'ai également une agence ici donc on
peut dire que depuis le début je suis la
référente germanophones sur tout ce qui
est lié au burlesque à Berlin cela m'a
permis de faire énormément de choses car
il n'y avait personne d'autre dans le
milieu
explain
comment le définit-on comment est la
sainte Burles en Allemagne et à Berlin
le burlesque est une sorte de reprise
d'une vieille forme de strip-tease qui
était très connue dans les années 40 aux
États-Unis cependant dans le burlesque
que nous nous intéressons pas tant à la
partie strip-tease mais surtout au côté
narratif depuis les années 40 le
strip-tease est de plus en plus
développé pour devenir progressivement
une danse plus sexuelle ce qui était
interdit à l'époque mais nous nous avons
repris l'ancienne idée du burlesque nous
ne montrons pas tout nous couvrons
toujours le bout de nos seins et portons
des culottes et nous racontons
l'histoire du personnage tout au long de
notre performance en enlevant nos
vêtements dans le même temps pour nous
le côté sexuel ne constitue pas le point
central de nos prestations contrairement
à ce qui est fait dans le strip-tease ce
qui nous intéresse c'est l'histoire de
la personne qui fait du burlesque et ce
qu'elle raconte à la fin nous célébrons
qui nous sommes et les personnes
incroyables que nous sommes
y a-t-il un style particulier
spécificités dans le burlesque allemand
quand j'ai commencé à faire du burlesque
en Allemagne c'était plutôt basé sur de
la comédie et sur quelque chose de
narratif principalement mais cela a
changé depuis le burlesque n'est plus
une forme de spectacle répétitif mais
quelque chose de vivant aujourd'hui on
porte tous des costumes glamour et
magnifique comme les Italiens ont
l'habitude d'en enfiler pour montrer
leur style de plus il existe une
certaine forme de séduction venant de
l'influence des États-Unis il s'agit
donc surtout d'un énorme mélange
culturel avec des artistes burlesques
qui viennent de l'étranger et qui
apportent leur fantastique d'influence
il est donc impossible d'affirmer tiens
voilà un artiste burlesque allemand
quelles sont les sources d'inspiration
du burlesque
comme le burlesque se base sur l'artiste
en lui-même et sur sa personnalité tout
peut parfaitement servir d'inspiration
un tableau qu'on a vu un livre qu'on a
écrit une musique et pas uniquement le
jazz mais ça peut être aussi du
rock'n'roll quelque chose de très
moderne peu importe
il n'y a pas de limite concernant
l'inspiration de chacun
c'est aussi cela qui fait le charme du
burlesque car à la fin d'un spectacle tu
restes toujours la même tu peux voir
quelqu'un à moitié nu sur scène mais ce
qui est spécialement intéressant c'est
de voir comment cette personne en arrive
jusque là c'est vraiment ça l'enjeu
c'est là que l'on retrouve les idées et
surprise les plus formidables
quand avez-vous créé le festival
burlesque de Berlin pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus à son sujet
a été créé plus ou moins au moment où
nous nous sommes rencontrés quand
j'étais à Berlin à cette époque il n'y
avait pas beaucoup d'artistes burlesques
lorsque je voyageais les conducteurs de
taxi me demandaient vous faites quoi
dans la vie burlesque c'est quoi
j'assistais à des festivals ces artistes
qui venaient de toute l’europe et
j'étais tellement triste de constater
que personne ne connaissait rien à ses
incroyables artistes et à cet art que
j'aimais et que j'aime toujours autant
sauver les choses c'est donc pour cette
raison que j'ai fondé le festival
burlesque de Berlin pour mettre en avant
cet art et pour montrer de quoi il
s'agit vraiment c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle nous veillons toujours à
avoir des profils très variés on
s'assure d'avoir à chaque fois des
boylesques des gens de différentes
nationalités des spectacles un peu
dingues charmants glamour
tout cela donne une explosion de joie
beaucoup de liberté pour faire une
grande force aux participants de plus
nous avons un public merveilleux qui est
presque devenu une famille
lorsqu'on assiste à un festival ou 40
femmes célèbres leur propre identité
vous pouvez facilement imaginer le type
de public intéressé un public qui aime
voir des gens se divertir
nous avons réussi d'ailleurs à créer une
très belle communauté qui ne cesse de
grandir avec le festival celui-ci est
organisé dans les salles historiques
berlinoises que sont Wintergarten et
alimentation call ainsi nous sommes
connectés au passé et aux années 20
quand il se passait déjà beaucoup de
choses pour moi c'est juste un
magnifique mélange d'individus doté
d'une énorme force qui se rencontre pour
s'amuser et qui ensuite retourne à leur
vie quotidienne toujours en partageant
leur joie et dans le respect de
l'expérience de chacun c'est ça ma
définition du festival
je ne peux pas te donner un style
précisément je recherche n'importe quel
spectacle de qualité même si c'est
complètement fou ou excessif le style
n'a aucune importance pour moi je
cherche vraiment des artistes qui
mettent tout ce qu'ils ont sur scène
avec la grande diversité de styles et
d'artistes qui existent je ne suis pas
intéressé en soi par l'enchaînement de
Thibault spectacles mais vraiment par la
diversité différentes couleurs de peau
différentes formes de corps tout cela
avec un trait au niveau qui se traduit
selon moi dans le caractère et
l'expression que déploie chaque artiste
dans sa performance et non pas par la
fantaisie du costume où son prix non
vraiment pour moi la haute performance
est portée d'abord par la personne le
burlesque m'a aussi permis de réaliser
que j'aimais les gens je ne le savais
pas avant avant j'étais plutôt du genre
à j'aime bien faire mon truc qui
exprimait mon art et puis hop foutez moi
la paix les gens n'étaient pas très
gentils non plus mais grâce au burlesque
que j'ai pu découvrir la bonté des gens
et c'est exactement cela que je
recherche des âmes qui s'expriment
librement
à 10 ans comment le burlesque a évolué
au fur et à mesure des années
many more j'aime bien cette question
elle me fait réfléchir quand je pense au
changement la première chose qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est qu'il y a
énormément plus d'artistes et donc plus
de concurrence il y a plus de travail
sans aucun doute mais je vois aussi la
concurrence comme quelque chose de
positif parce qu'elle booste les gens et
oblige les concurrents à s'investir
davantage pour leur passion pour ce
qu'ils font le nombre d'artistes
burlesque c'est certainement multiplié
mais quand le festival a commencé le but
est de voir les spectacles de ces
magnifiques artistes des artistes avec
une grande force et très connectée entre
eux ils se connaissaient ils connaissait
les histoires des uns et des autres leur
situation familiale l'univers du
bourlesque a beaucoup évolué mais il a
également gagné en sophistication
lorsque je pense au passé je ne sais pas
si c'est ton cas mais la plupart de mes
costumes étaient faits à la main et
cousue et j'étais ravie quand la lumière
s'allumait sur la scène car on ne
pouvait pas voir comment les pièces
étaient collées parfois j'étais obligé
de les agrafer l'univers du burlesque a
gagné donc en termes de sophistication
puisqu'il y a plus d'argent sur le
marché je ne veux pas juger de cette
évolution cela ne fait pas du burlesque
un univers meilleur ou pire je ne veux
vraiment pas juger de cela je crois
qu'il y a juste plus de personnes qui le
pratiquent
personnellement je préfère toujours
rester proche des belles personnes parce
que je ne crois pas vraiment aux
alliances à l'union entre nous et à la
création d'un réseau à mon sens le plus
important est de s'assurer que notre
scène et nos coulisses restent des
endroits sûrs peu importe l'ampleur que
nous avons pris que personne ne nous
traite de haut ou quelque chose comme ça
on peut donc dire que je fais partie de
la communauté hippie du burlesque je
ressens l'amour et je suis contente que
celui-ci continue de grandir
[Musique]
et avant de se quitter dans zone Europe
on va s'intéresser maintenant aux
traditions de Noël ici en Allemagne Anna
et Cécilia vous avez fait le tour je
crois du marché de Noël vous avez ramené
avec nous quelques exemples oui 40 ans
effectivement pour la plupart des gens
le marché de Noël c'est avant tout le
vin chaud la boisson ils vendu sur les
nombreux États notamment dans de petits
gobelets comme celle-ci
que vous pouvez même souvent garder oui
et non une petite caution
il y a ensuite
c'est ce petit cœur avec marqué ich
liebe dich comment est-ce que ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle les courgettes
autre les amandes torréfiées les pommes
d'amour et les fruits enrobés de
chocolat
les soi-disant les courgettes donc
celui-là
sans l'incarnation des marchés de Noël
des grands et des petits sont
enthousiasmés par ce classique car on
parle d'épices bonds aromatiques qui
avec le
ne obligatoire peut être porté autour du
coude
pour les amoureux et enfin donc vous
nous avez ramené une boule de Noël si je
crois bien si je vois bien en tout cas
oui
en Allemagne de sapins de Noël oui bien
sûr c'est obligatoire d'avoir un sapin
de Noël dans tous les maisons en
Allemagne et évidemment c'est
obligatoire de les décorer et vous le
mettez à partir de quand du premier
décembre ou un peu avant ça dépend moi
notre famille oui à partir du 1er
décembre parce que le décembre c'est
quand même le mois de Noël mais il y a
aussi des familles qui commencent le 24
décembre aussi
à la fin pour finir donc
on a ce objet de décoration
c'est si aussi obligatoire dans tous les
maisons parce que ça ça donne un bon
esprit de Noël c'est joli ça c'est oui
et bien merci beaucoup Cécilia merci
beaucoup Anna d'avoir été avec nous dans
une Europe merci aussi au fond citoyen
franco-allemand pour avoir soutenu cette
émission et vous pouvez retrouver ce
numéro de zone Europe vous le savez en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site
Internet et sur notre application radio
sensation très belle soirée à tous
[Musique]
avec le soutien financier du fond
citoyen franco-allemand